all suffering originates from craving
from attachment
from desire
i have great faith in fools
self-confidence my friends will call it
those who dream by day are cognizant of
many things
which escape those who dream only by
night
i became insane
with long intervals of horrible sanity
[Music]
all that we see or seem
is but a dream within a dream
we loved with the love
that was more than love
i was never really insane except upon
occasions
when my heart was touched
there is no exquisite beauty without
some strangeness in the proportion
[Music]
believe nothing you hear
and only one half
that you see
years of love have been forgotten
in the hatred of a minute
never to suffer
would never to have been blessed
words have no power to impress the mind
without the exquisite horror of their
reality
all religion my friend
has simply evolved out of fraud fear
greed
imagination and poetry
if you wish to forget anything on the
spot
make a note that this thing is to be
remembered
beauty of whatever kind in its supreme
development
invariably excites the sensitive soul to
tears
invisible things
are the only realities
the death of a beautiful woman is
unquestionably
the most poetical topic in the world
science has not yet taught us if madness
is or is not
the sublimity of intelligence
there are some secrets which do not
permit themselves to be told
poetry is the rhythmical creation of
beauty and words
it is a happiness to wonder
it is the happiness to dream
[Music]
to elevate the soul
poetry is necessary
the boundaries which divide life from
death
are at best shadowy and vague
who shall say where the one ends
and where the other begins
there are cords in the hearts of the
most reckless
which cannot be touched without emotion
even in the grave
all has not lost
to die laughing must be the most
glorious of all glorious deaths
[Music]
every poem should remind the reader
that they are going to die
a short story must have a single mood
and every sentence
must build towards it
stupidity is a talent for misconception
art is to look at
not to criticize
experience has shown
and a true philosophy will always show
that a vast perhaps the larger portion
of truth
arises from the seemingly irrelevant
a man's grammar like caesar's wife
should not only be pure
but above suspicion of impurity
mysteries force a man to think
and so injure his health
the scariest monsters
are the ones that lurk within our souls
the idea of god
infinity
or spirit stands for the possible
attempt at an impossible conception
there is an eloquence in true enthusiasm
when a madman appears thoroughly saying
indeed
it is high time to put him in a straight
jacket
[Music]
imperceptibly
the love of these discords grew upon me
as my love of music grew stronger
the eye
like a shattered mirror
multiplies the images of sorrow
the depth lies in the valleys where we
seek her
and not upon the mountaintops where she
is found
[Music]
if they say bad things about you
then they just envy you
loneliness in old age often means a
deterioration in relationship with the
remaining relatives and friends
as the elderly person begins to demand
constant attention from them
the best cure for loneliness in old age
is a pet
if a poem hasn't ripped apart your soul
you haven't experienced poetry
even for those
to whom life and death are equal just
there are some things that are still
held in respect
marking a book is literally an
experience of your differences or
agreements with the author
it is the highest respect you can pay
him
it is impossible to say how first the
idea entered my brain
but once conceived
it haunted me day and night
and so being young
and dipped in folly
i fell in love with melancholy
there is no passion in nature so
demonically impatient
as that of him who
shuddering upon the edge of a precipice
thus meditates a plunge
as a poet and as a mathematician
he would reason well
as a mere mathematician
he could not have reasoned at all
who has not a hundred times
found himself committing a vile or a
silly action for no other reason
than because he knows he should not
and have i not told you that what you
mistake for madness
is but over acuteness of the sense
you will observe that the stories told
are all about
money seekers
not about money finders
that man is not truly brave who was
afraid either to seem or to be
when it suits him a coward
the pioneers and missionaries of
religion
have been the real cause of more trouble
and war
than all other classes of mankind
music
when combined with a pleasurable idea
is poetry
music without the idea
is simply music
the idea without the music
is prose
from its very definitiveness
if we cannot comprehend god in his
visible works
how then in his inconceivable thoughts
that call the works into being
it would be mockery to call such
dreariness heaven at all
if you are ever drowned or hung
be sure to make a note of your
sensations
to observe a tentatively
is to remember distinctly
for all we live to know
is known
you